[Music]
the new s5 rounds out out ease a 5
Series it features the same elegant
contours as the coupe a it's based on
lightweight materials save a good 40
kilograms over the a4 convertible while
stabilizing sheet steel makes for a nice
least if body structure
[Music]
that contact car tester Claus needs fits
notes the excellent contact with the
road in the new dynamic steering system
which lets the driver virtually feel the
road surface through the steering wheel
to stun spirit without finding absolute
top he also likes the s5s new engine a
three litre 260 kilowatt v6 that carries
the car from zero to 100 km/h and 5.1
seconds a starting price of not quite
68,000 euros in Germany what's the
convertibles price tag at about 5,000
euros higher than the coupe A's
[Music]
when could the dog close says driving a
convertible fast when it's open doesn't
make a lot of sense but with the top up
it's surprisingly quiet inside Howdy's
developed an acoustic roof to reduce
noise almost to the level of the Koopas
interior in contrast to that the sound
is a blast when the sportier five
flashes past
[Music]
Klose describes the handling as in
general quite balanced the car
understeers just a bit when you head
into sharp curves and step on the gas
moving the center of gravity over the
front axle but he says that's normal and
absolutely okay the adaptive damping
suspension can adjust automatically to
speed in road conditions
[Music]
the soft-top opens automatically in just
15 seconds even while the car is moving
at speeds up to 50 km/h it takes 18
seconds to close
much of what costs extra on the a5 has
become standard on the s5 the
convertible sports a good 30 drivers
assists including adaptive cruise
control with stop-and-go that even takes
over steering for the driver at speeds
up to 65 km/h and monitors the distance
to the car ahead
so in slow-moving traffic the driver can
almost kick back and relax
[Applause]
this outie is just as convincing on the
inside as well the materials have a high
quality look and feel the twelve point
three inch TFT display is sharp and
brilliant
[Music]
the sports seats are upholstered in a
combination of Alcantara fabric and
leather
[Music]
the s5 has enough room and back for
additional passengers plus 380 litres of
cargo space in the generous trunk
[Applause]
I'm Edith cowboy if Klaus says buyers
should definitely choose the automatic
transmission to get the most fun out of
the convertible the 8-speed Tiptronic in
his test car works perfectly over always
says the new Audi s5 is truly a snappy
convertible with plenty of power and
good looks at the base version lists for
over sixty seven thousand euros in
Germany so a few options can push the
total price up to 80,000 mr. David our
mid after thousand or ovations in
business as in life the good things on
the road have their price
[Applause]
[Music]
physics will be a car tester Emmanuelle
Schaefer says viewers who know car
interiors might think he's sitting in a
Mercedes but they'd be wrong
it's an Infiniti more specifically a
qx30 that's because the Nissan Division
has an agreement with Mercedes Benz
which allowed them to come up with their
own interpretation of the Mercedes GLA
class SUV there's hardly any difference
inside only the logo on the steering
wheel and the infotainment system the
rest has been taken over from Mercedes
the controls on the steering wheel as
well as the switches for lights windows
mirrors electronics seat adjustment and
many other visible and invisible parts
are identical from Manoa says from the
outside only the rough basic form
reminds us of the GLA in fact the front
with its relatively flat tapered
headlights is fairly unconventional and
also more aggressive than its German
sibling
we're testing the 2.2 liter diesel it
delivers 125 kilowatts and accelerates
the qx30 from 0 to 100 km/h and 8.5
seconds the top speed is 215 km/h only
one other engine is available a 2-liter
155 kilowatt gasoline engine both come
with all-wheel drive and a 7-speed
dual-clutch transmission as standard
Manawa says when it comes to powertrain
and suspension the GLA is sporty-er and
that means stiffer if the qx30 feels
much more solid and relaxed but also a
bit slower
the suspension is a little soft and that
enhances travel comfort on long journeys
the motto says there's another minor
difference that might appeal to people
thinking about a qx30 the shifter for
the automatic transmission is located in
the center console just as on most cars
except for Mercedes where it's behind
the steering wheel just like the
windshield wiper lever the 2.2 litre
diesel does its job with aplomb it's not
exactly loud but always audible a little
more sound insulation would have done it
good the design is expressive the long
pronounced contours unmistakably
Japanese the higher of the two equipment
lines has adaptive LED headlights with
automatic high-beam estándares
[Music]
except he says he's relatively tall at 1
metres 80 and while the front seats were
fine it's pretty tight in the rear so if
a tall person sits in front or in back
not much room is left over and that's
not much head roof yeah the trunk of a
qx30 holds 430 liters the short list of
available options is a positive aspect
the two equipment lines premium and
premium tech don't leave you guessing so
things like start/stop systems lane
guards and parking sensors are already
included in our test the qx30 guzzles
quite a bit more than it's rated for at
a constant 120 km/h it consumes nearly 6
litres per 100 kilometres instead of the
4.9 claimed Manawa says at the end of
the day the qx30 is like a more
courageous goe in terms of design alone
when it comes to the price there is not
much difference with a similarly
equipped GLA costing around 1,000 euros
more so the main selling point for the
qx30 is really the design and it's
greater long-distance comfort the
Infiniti qx30 starts in just over 39,000
euros in Germany
[Music]
the valar is the new member of the Range
Rover family the midsize crossover SUV
fits between the e-book and Sport models
it's based on Jaguar Land Rovers
lightweight aluminum platform and shares
a lot of technology with the Jaguar
f'hace
but features an entirely new design
language Huzhou is getting ready to
launch its new five thousand eight seven
seater family SUV it has the longest
wheelbase in its class its boxy hood and
high side lines give the new Fuzhou a
bullish look the squared off rear means
there's plenty of cargo space making the
5008 a convenient day-to-day hauler
[Music]
say 'it has led it's revised leon cupra
loose on the racetrack and the street
380 Newton meters of torque provide
plenty of power see that says the
five-door coupe rail with DSG or direct
shift gearbox accelerates from 0 to 100
km/h and 5.7 seconds a special
differential lock ensures that the
ancient always gives the most power to
the wheel with the best road grip car
tester undulate zimmerman says the leon
cupra has made substantial advances that
now has 221 kilowatts of power a modern
front axle lock can't completely keep a
lead foot from wasting all that power
producing smoke and making the car
understeer but with a little sensitivity
fuel can be well dosed and the steering
is very direct from Garcia to Zn without
the Lincoln is dead elect
[Music]
- for the racetrack Andre suggest going
for the performance package including
the Michelin Pilot Sport cup 2 tires
their outer flank has a much larger
rubber surface so if you go into a curve
fast the car leans onto this flank for
the best possible grip of didn't best
nutation Clubman the Cupra is a sports
car for normal streets but thanks to the
special Brembo brake system in the
performance package you can take it on
to a real race track without worrying
that you'll burn up the brakes
LED headlamps are standard in the Cupra
the racetrack suit in Cooper with DSG
and five-door starts at about 40,000
euros our tester climbs into the newly
revised Cupra st the station wagon is
quite a bit quieter than the versions
with less trunk space
[Music]
[Music]
the station wagons target clientele are
long-distance drivers and families so
the developers decided against a loud
exhaust system otherwise it has the same
technical highlights as the normal Cupra
and is definitely sporting
Andre says the Cupra three and five-door
models have undergone evolution while
the station wagon has been through a
real revolution it is the only current
Cooper model that's available with
all-wheel drive country pop and cons and
the all-wheel drive variant always
provided with DSG takes just 4.9 seconds
to reach 100 kilometers an hour top
speed is electronically limited to 250
kilometers an hour as a man Andre is
quite taken with the new Cooper whether
in the front wheel or the all-wheel
version for people who want to set
records at least their own on a race
track front-wheel drive is best simply
because the car is lighter but those who
buy the station wagon will be very
satisfied - especially when they find
themselves on a snowy closed-off road we
put that assertion to the test we tried
out the all-wheel drive under extreme
conditions of frozen lake in Finland
[Music]
car tester I know Dyson / uses the
opportunity to dance his Cooper ST
around the curves in a controlled drift
des noisy I know the new Cupra with
all-wheel-drive is even more fun than
the front wheel drive version forget
spinning wheels when you accelerate out
of a curve and after that first curve
you'll forget the extra 100 kilos that
come with all wheel drive if you turn
off the electronic assist skill with a
steering wheel and gas pedal let's the
rear swing out at least on snow and ice
that makes driving a station wagon fun
I do see at Leon Cupra is the most
powerful see out ever since I know and
with all-wheel drive it's also the best
but it's too bad if you don't like
station wagons because the standard
three or five-door versions aren't
available with both all-wheel drive and
the larger engine
[Music]
the Alps the perfect setting for
all-wheel vehicles
we'll take a close look at new releases
and old friends here unpaved and gravel
passes and mountain roads in the
Dolomites the increased ground clearance
makes sense here our five SUVs are the
big boys of this popular vehicle type
but they have long since achieved the
status of the s-class or BMW 7 class and
their prices show it so it's hardly
surprising the brands like Jaguar and
Maserati have now come out with SUVs too
let's start with the Italian a few years
ago an off-road vehicle from the luxury
carmaker would have been unthinkable but
feeis luxury subsidiary has done its
homework and it's been a real boon for
the company the levant is already the
trident brands cash cow
[Music]
the secret of its success remain a
typical Maserati but jacked up a little
higher that's its main difference from
the G bleep we're already familiar with
Maseratis all-wheel sedan what's new
here is that pneumatic suspension has
enabled Maserati to increase the
levonne's ground clearance that makes
the dapper vehicle off-road capable to a
degree things are similar with the
Jaguar FPS this off-roader is a Jaguar
through and through down to the radiator
emblem in the front it's like an XF and
the rear an F that's it and it's already
the company's fastest selling model ever
form and craftsmanship are as admirable
and Jaguars SUV as in its sedans unusual
for an SUV is the F pieces aluminum
construction which keeps its weight
under 1,800 kilograms the advantage is
obvious on mountain passes inter alia
the F pace is one of the most agile SUVs
it's Diesel's 221 kilowatts are more
than adequate and the automatic
transmission moves precisely through its
eight speeds the height of the adaptive
suspension can't be adjusted but it can
be set to sporty or comfortable as
desired
[Music]
the Lexus RX 450h is an old acquaintance
in Alta Badia its third edition came on
the market in 2015 the hybrid SUV is a
top seller in the United States but
still a rare sight in Germany probably
because its appearance polarizes its 230
kilowatts give it plenty of speed but
despite its all-wheel-drive this hybrid
is just not right for off-road adventure
[Music]
for that jeeps Grand Cherokee won't
steer you wrong this good old boy and
co-founder of the SUV segment is a real
all-rounder as robust as an earthmover
it's the only SUV we're looking at that
is really at home offroad thanks to its
adjustable clearance it takes rugged
slopes like the Jeep it is but all the
little buttons on the instrument panel
show that the big Jeep is getting on an
updated model could change that the
please not the smooth ride on pavement
[Music]
thanks to numerous safety and assist
systems the Volvo xc90 is especially
secure but not as sporty or off-road
suited as the competition the second
generation gets points for its clear
calm design which is also reflected in
the interiors top quality materials the
Swedish giant is also available with
seven seats and plug-in hybrid drive the
bottom line is that these large SUVs
enjoy high status and are constantly
improving but they still ghusl a lot
more gas than classic sedans or station
wagons hybrid engines and downsizing can
only do so much
[Music]
a beautiful blast from the past and an
extremely rare one at that Christoph
Bauer is driving a piece of automotive
history the Porsche name is displayed
proudly at the back but this car was
built and - in Switzerland not in
Porsches hometown of stud guide
the gold ivory stuff explains that when
the auto industry was in its infancy
cars were made by hand the big
manufacturers only provided the chassis
the engine and the fittings customers
had to order the body individually from
a coach maker by the 1950s this practice
was rare but the boiler firm from - and
Switzerland continued to do excellent
bodywork one example is this wonderful
coupe a a 1957 Volkswagen Porsche boiler
696 instant Fritz boiler had already
established contacts at Porsche back in
1948 six - the very first porsche 356s
had bodies made by the boiler brothers
including the oldest series production
porsche is still in existence car number
zero zero three but the coach makers had
aspirations of their own elegant coupe a
with four seats and superior engineering
that drives like a sports car
impossible no said instant fit spoiler
they acquired the chassis of a VW Bug
and began to hammer out a suitable body
and this was the fruit of their labor
the Porsche boiler 696 a real
eye-catcher
the body of the boiler Porsche 696 was
made entirely of aluminum this
particular 4-door coupe a was fitted
with an engine that normally powered
Porsche sports cars the other boiler 696
is used a reliable and cheaper mass
production engine produced by Volkswagen
demise the boy's boiler coupe ace were
powered by the VW Beetle engine explains
Christoph with a Judson compressor
providing extra performance but that
wasn't enough for this cars first owner
hear that sound right
that's Porsches engineering in the back
Christoph says the four-cylinder boxer
engine generated 75 horsepower and
pushed the coupe a to a top speed of 165
kilometers an hour just the thing for
those looking to live life in the fast
lane in the late 50s
though it's a product of the 1950's the
boiler styling is coolly understated but
then the Swiss do like to remain neutral
the only extravagant feature is the mock
radiator grille because in fact this
cars engine is in the rear
the interiors monochrome color scheme
looked smart with a radio from Blaupunkt
and high-quality leather upholstery the
boiler Porsche was both luxurious and
suitable for everyday use the trunk at
the front can hold quite a bit more than
just a golf bag
until and here at the back is the
legendary Porsche boxer engine from the
356 8 its twin Zenith carburetors allow
it to generate 75 horsepower this engine
alone costs 3600 Swiss francs more than
the standard VW won but Christophe says
it's worth every cent team in its day
only the rich could afford to own one
[Music]
Christophe says in 1957 this Coupe a
sold for almost 20 thousand Swiss francs
as much as four standard VW beetles but
exclusivity has its price and the Swiss
could afford the better things in life
still Switzerland is a small country
such as for these coupe pays were ever
sold as boiler kept the fifth one for
himself and drove it until the 1990s
just five of these upscale cars were
ever built using engineering borrowed
from Porsche and Volkswagen and a
hand-hammered body from a small Swiss
coach maker so can the boiler Coupe a
really qualify as a milestone in
automotive history the boiler brothers
were the first in Europe to make a four
seater sports coupe a without standing
driving characteristics it would be many
years until cars like the VW Scirocco
Ford Capri and Opel Manta introduced the
idea to the masses so for that reason
Christoph feels the Volkswagen Porsche
boiler is definitely an automotive
milestone and the boiler Coupe a is also
one of the most beautiful cars ever made
what a shame that the tradition of
making car bodies by hand is slowly
dying out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you